hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name as
always is alex mollering and tonight
we're going to be looking at
at least one maybe two
of
probably the most popular most famous
and arguably most fundamental uh
beginner end games
that
involve more than just the king and upon
there's a lot of end games where it's
either like the king in one other piece
maybe your checkmating with a king and a
queen or king and a rook or you're
trying to promote to one of those pieces
with the king of the pawn but we're
going to take
one step out and look at the most
fundamental end games for the king
a rook and a pawn where both sides have
a rook so to start this out
it is going to be important to remember
some of the kind of fundamental ideas
that are present in general end games
so i've started with this king and pawn
end game because it does there is some
instructive stuff here that we're going
to need to keep in mind
as we add the pieces and add some
complexity
so in a position like this it doesn't
matter whose turn to move it is but
white is absolutely winning this game
the reason is because the king is in
front of the pawn
if there's any two things you keep in
mind from this lesson
um
i would say that when you're in an
endgame scenario an end game is any time
that the king becomes an active piece
and usually the position is very
simplified there's not a lot of pieces
left
um in any end game
but especially end games where you have
a pawn that you are trying to promote
usually this will be a past pawn or a
pawn that has no
opponent pawns that can either block or
threaten to capture it
in these cases then the kings belong in
front of the pawns that's the first
thing to remember and the second thing
when we add in rooks rooks belong behind
past pawns we'll talk about why but if
you can just keep any two rules in mind
those are the ones you want to keep the
kings belong in front of the pawns and
the rooks belong behind the pawns
and we'll actually see the reason for
this right it doesn't matter which color
you are or whether you have the pawn or
not in this position
with white to move the best move for
white is to keep the king in front of
the pawn and play a move like king to d5
advancing forward taking up space and
threatening to move in so whichever way
the black king chooses to move if they
move to the blue square here on c7 then
white will advance on the blue line
towards e6 and vice versa with the
yellow squares but either way
white is moving forward
um black can try and stop you know the
hang of the pawn but
as long as you keep your in front
until you get to the very end of the
board then you should be able to win
right in this position it's very
important to keep the king in front of
the pawn by playing the move king to d6
forcing your opponent out of the way and
stepping in if you want to look more in
detail at these lines there's another
lecture i've given and lots of other
lectures on youtube about how to win
with a king and a pawn
so i definitely recommend checking those
out but that's the basic idea because if
we're in this position
it's white to move and we play this move
king to d6 we're actually now in a draw
because our king is behind the pawn and
has no way to support it moving forwards
so black can take opposition here uh
where they are looking directly across
from our king there's no way our king
can move forward so the only way to try
and make progress is to push the pawn
and the king will step in front
putting us in an awkward bind
where if we
maintain our defense of the pawn
it's actually a stalemate black's king
has nowhere safe to go all of these
squares are controlled but it's not
check so the game is a
draw or
we can step away from the pawn but then
it's not defended and black will just
capture it and it's a draw either way
black can force this however if we were
to play a really bad move in this
position like e3 the king is in front of
the pawn yes but black can play this
move important move king to d6 and
basically do what we just did to them
now they're the ones who are setting the
pace we have to move to one of the sides
since there's no forward option and
whichever side we choose if we go to the
yellow side black will mirror us
if we go to the blue side
it'll be the exact same thing
and the only way to try and make
progress will be eventually to
we can keep dancing forever but we're
never going to move forward so you can
try and push the pawn forward but notice
how our king is now next to the pawn not
in front of it and black will
essentially be able to
body guard all of these squares keep our
king from ever stepping in front of the
pawn again
and this should be an easy draw for
black
so pings belong in front of the pawns if
you are aside trying to promote your
king leading the way will help defend
those squares and allow you to actually
get the pawn to the end of the board and
if your opponent if you are sorry if
your opponent has the pawn
then you getting your king in front will
essentially be able to stay their hand
stop them from defending the key squares
and you'll just be able to maintain your
space
now
let's add
some complications
before we jump into the main positions
so we're going to be looking at the
lucina position in depth and depending
on time we may get to the filador
position
i i'm guessing we're going to have
enough to cover with just the first one
but those are what to expect from this
lecture but before we get to that i want
to also give a few kind of of the basic
tips and tricks that are just going to
be relevant in general
for the king and rook and pawn end games
so here's a position that highlights all
the unique dangers that happen here and
what both sides should be looking out
for
so in this position uh it is white's
turn to move and this position is a dead
draw but there are a lot of ways for
black to go wrong
um so
for instance the first thing to note is
both of the kings are very far away and
it's going to take a very long time for
either of them to try and get anywhere
near this pawn
the second is that black's rook is on a
really good square notice how it is
behind the past pawn as i already said
and white's work is in front this
already shows one of the reasons why the
rook wants to be behind because a rook
behind a pawn
can guard all of the squares where the
pawn wants to go if you're defending it
you can help push it forward and if
you're attacking it you cover every
place it's going to be until the very
end of the board
alternatively a rook in front of the
pawn is still okay you are defending it
but it's not nearly as good because
especially when you get to a
circumstance like this this work now
needs to leave right this rook has to
get to some other space in order to
allow the pawn to move forward and
promote the problem is because black's
work is here
any time we leave then black's work will
happily just eat this pawn
and there's no silly tricks right now we
can't just play something like rook to
g8 check
and promote because we haven't dealt
with this rook it's just going to eat
the pawn and we're going to look a
little silly
so not the position we have as it stands
and essentially it's white to move the
only move that doesn't give away the
pawn is to move the king right we can't
push the pawn and any move we play with
the rook uh is not going to defend the
pawn even this one that attacks the king
because the rook is still going to take
it on the next move so white should
simply try and advance the king
and here's where black can go very
terribly wrong because black has a very
easy draw in this position
but there's a lot of mistakes you can
make
so for instance
um if black
tries to bring in the king i think a
very basic strategy
would seem to be
well my king is going to be closer i can
use my rook to hold the king off
from ever approaching so i'm just going
to bring my king in
attack the rook and the pawn at the same
time the rook is going to have to move i
will take the pawn with my king or my
rook
and the game will be a very easy draw
king and rook versus king and rook no
need to stress there
the problem is this king is actually
defending some very critical squares
because anywhere this king moves uh that
doesn't defend essentially the the two
critical squares or areas will result in
a deadly deadly loss for black
the first option again very simple move
just king to f7 approaching the pawn
the problem with this move is white has
an excellent response white can play
this stunning move rook to h8
clearing the space for the pawn to
promote
and the problem for black is now uh you
have to take the pawn if you don't then
it's just promoting
calling check forever isn't going to
work because i can just move my king in
and the position won't actually change
at all
i'm just going to have my king closer to
your rook
and when you do end up taking the pawn
then white has this really nasty skewer
rook to h7 check the king has to move
out of the way we're going to pick up
the rook
and this should be a very easy win for
white
so the king has to stay guarding of this
square area here on h8 and h7 and the
king can't stay in this line if it's
going to get
too far away from these squares
otherwise the rook's going to be able to
come in and call check
okay well what if instead
we get off of this line altogether and
play king to f6
well now the trick we saw at the
beginning does work right now i can play
rook to f8 because it's check and your
king can't take the rook
the problem is wherever your king goes
to attack it now i can safely promote
because even though you can take my
queen my work now defends it these
pieces defend each other so you can't
take the rook anymore and if you take
the queen i take back with the rook
something like this
and once again this would be a very easy
win for white the king and the rook
versus the king i also believe i did a
lecture on that i think if you look up
rookie's guide to rooks you should find
that if you want to know how to
checkmate with a king and a rook versus
a king
okay so this is what black has to watch
out for anytime you step away
from
this
second to last rank you're allowing
white to call check and then promote so
that's no good but if you step
away from this file then the root can
come back and threaten a skewer
so there's actually just
nothing black can do to make progress
here
probably the best move would just be to
play king to h7 passing
um white's going to continue to advance
the good news
for black this is still a very easy draw
um because the king is just going to go
back and forth
eventually the king will approach this
rook but now um we have a few options
this one can kind of go anywhere at once
on this file importantly you can't move
the rook off of this file
because once again if we were to play
something like rook to h2 trying to keep
the king locked to the back well we've
given up our crucial defense of these
squares
so now once again tactics like rook to
g8 appear you have to be ready for an
option like this right because now
promotion is coming with check and the
rook is no longer there to capture the
piece
so instead um i should just play a move
you know pulling the rook back and this
is going to allow the king to approach
but again the good news for black is
this doesn't matter because there's no
way to actually make progress here
we can continue to cult check over and
over forever
um because this rook is in the way and
the king essentially doesn't have
anywhere to hide um so no matter what
happens we can just continue to move
back and forth and call check and if the
king ever approaches
the rook again then we can just stay on
this file and black has an easy draw
for that matter all the way back in the
beginning position you know black
doesn't even need to
stop the king
staying on this row you could just play
move like rook to a1 check
and it's not going to make any
difference
so these are some of the ideas to keep
in mind right um
look out for checks where rook can get
something get out of the way we can
promote um keep an eye on this idea
where
you're gonna need some kind of safety
net to keep the king safe otherwise the
rook can just check you forever and
you're not going to make progress
but these are some things we're going to
look out for and here's where we enter
our main position
this is called the lucy
um hello thinker teacher welcome with
the raid
uh glad to have you here
so we're looking at the lucina position
um it is a very famous and there's a few
things important to note so in this type
of position um you want to keep an eye
out
the king is in front of the pawn
about to promote
um
so the problem we have here is instead
of the rook being in the way of
promotion it's the king
um
white's rook is just kind of hanging off
to the side trying to keep black's king
away from attacking the pawn because if
for whatever reason black's king and
rook could double up on the pawn they
could try and win it so the rook is just
kind of holding black's king off at the
same time black's king is keeping white
from escaping
along with the rook
because black realizes as long as white
can't move their king out of the way
then there's nothing to worry about the
pawn can't ever promote if the king is
stuck on d8
so the question is
how can white try and make progress in
this position
um well in order to win there are two
things the white has to do
and they are very basic right two
fundamental things we have to move the
king out of the way of the pawn
and then we have to promote the pawn
not too complicated but in practice it's
a little harder than it looks
there's a lot of different ways to try
and go about this position a lot of ways
that have been tried
but there's one tried and true method
that i'm going to share
and then i'll show some other ideas so i
first want to show something that
doesn't work
there's a move that a lot of players
might look at this position and try
um
thinking okay if i can just force this
king away
it's going to be harder to deal with the
rook right because my king is in no
position to help defend my rook so i
can't actually challenge this piece
but i can challenge the king right if i
can get the king to step away i can give
my king an escape square essentially and
allow the pawn to promote so a lot of
people might try something like rook to
e7
hoping to just force black's king away
um this unfortunately doesn't work
so there's only really one good move in
this position
black has to play king to f8
keeping the king
nearby and again taking away this escape
square and white can continue to check
but it's not actually going to amount to
anything right we're just going to keep
repeating and white's not making any
progress
um
now black can blunder here right if
black moves away and stops you know
attacking this square then now white's
easily winning because the king can just
step out of the way
um and promotion is unstoppable
so
uh the king needs to stay in guard but
rook to e7 isn't going to help
accomplish that
so what else should we do
well
there's a few methods
the one i'm going to show you is what i
think of as the no stress chest method
this is kind of my philosophy when it
comes to chess
is what is the simplest way i can solve
a position
so a few people in the chat are
suggesting um the correct move and the
correct move is rook to f2
so work type 2 is different than rook to
e7 because here black now has a more
uncomfortable choice
um
if black plays king to e6 trying to stay
near by the pawn this just loses
immediately because of king e8
and now normally what we would like to
do is whenever this king steps out of
the way the rook wants to jump in and
call check
and keep forcing the king to dance
around well now that the king's in the
way
the black king is in the way there's no
checks so this pawn is just very simply
promoting
so that means the king has to back off
the black's king just say goes to g7
wanting to stay close to the pawn maybe
not wanting to get on the edge of the
board g7 seems like a very reasonable
square
and this is where it gets really tricky
if you haven't seen this rook f2 seems
reasonable to find
but the problem here is there's a lot of
different ideas if anyone in the chat
knows the next move
then feel free to throw it in the chat
okay i think someone showed it but i
want to also talk about
why so someone says rook f5 someone says
rook f4
okay
and dark tiger three asking is this one
where we build a bridge yes this is
exactly what we're doing um
so
to kind of go back
we just looked at king e6 and said this
is bad because it stops you know it
stops the rook from being able to check
our king
um this is kind of black building our
bridge for us but often your opponent is
not going to cooperate so we need to
play a move that builds a bridge
and the right move here is rook to f4
in order to explain this move i do want
to show a few alternatives that also
look so good
move that you could try right here would
be something like k to e7 just with a
very simple idea you could play king to
e8 it would do the same thing
but the idea is okay we force the king
away we're stepping out of the way of
the pawn so now
let's promote
the problem is now the checks well if
anyone here is familiar with smash mouth
uh famous song all-star the checks start
coming and they don't stop coming
it's just going to continue to happen
and
you can kind of hide behind the rook
you're going to have to get too far away
from the pawn right now something like
rook d1 and i still can't promote it's
just going to get taken i can go back to
defend and check again
white is not making any progress here so
this is why the concept of building a
bridge is so important
white king is free to roam around but
can't avoid all of these checks so black
is going to hold if this is all that
white tries to do
again king to e8 it's going to be the
exact same idea tricks are going to
happen and we're going to get forced
back in front of the pawn and again
black wants to stop white from escaping
so something like rook to c1 and again
the position is returning to where it
was before
and finally checking more or white
doesn't do anything right we can play
something like this but our whole point
was to try and get the king away so this
isn't getting us anywhere either
um
yeah i see why w04 if we have time at
the end we will get to the philidor
position that's the second really
fundamental rook and uh king position i
want to kind of the
explanation here main difference between
the two positions so philidor and lucina
both very famous um the difference is
whether is whose king is in front right
remember we started with this notion
that kings belong in front of pawns
whether you're the uh be on the
offensive or on the defensive you want
your king to be in front
um in the lucina position white can win
because white's king is in front of the
pawn
in the philidor position black's gonna
win because their king is in front of
the pawn
it's certainly more complicated than
that but that's the very boiled down
version and i'm sorry i said black's
gonna win black's gonna draw but that's
the best outcome they can hope for
um i guess unless white gives up their
rook too for no reason okay
so back to
the idea so rook to f2 forcing the king
away into g7 and now rook to f4
this move looks very odd
and very specific
um but there's a reason for it the
reason we need to as we've said we need
to build a bridge
what that means is we need to create
something to block the onslaught of
checks that are going to come for our
our opponent's rook
and here's how you figure out where does
this work actually go why is it f4 why
is it not f5
these types of questions well the reason
is we want to think about once the
checks start to occur
how far away can our king ever get from
this pawn
the answer is only one square right if
we look at this example and imagine we
just move the king right away
then after check
check
we need to stay really close to the pawn
whenever the check is on the same line
as it
but when the check is not right now if
we move our king away from the pawn
black can't take it we get one move so
you can play a move like king to d5
in this position nothing changes because
we are still checked but here's what you
want to notice the king can have one
space between it and the pawn because
that's how chess works it's a turn-based
game
and for us to build a bridge we want to
put something right here we want to use
our rook to get right in front of our
king
where does that end up in this case it
ends up being f4 so that's the process
we're going to think of
when we're back in this position we're
going to think okay where does my rook
need to be i need it to block the check
and i need it to be as far as i need to
get my king as far away as possible to
make it easier on my rook because if i
go to f5
then now there might be some issues of
black's king harassing art rook being a
little too close for comfort um
so we don't want to go too far
um
but here we go say okay our king is
going to come up there's maybe going to
be some checks but eventually we can get
one row
farther up which means
we need the rook to come right here to
block
what that looks like is we play rook to
f4
now black doesn't really have anything
they can do in this position um so
they're just going to pass a move right
so it's going to play rook to c2 they
need to keep blocking this line
if they played something like king to g6
just moving their king it's also a
passing move nothing's going to change
our strategy is going to be the same we
move the king out of the way
and
eventually we prepare to move forward
but once again when the rook checks the
king
and the pawn in the same line you want
to be careful not to get too excited and
move the king away and just give up the
pawn this is very sad
instead you want to just you know add
your time be patient move to the side
they still need to check you and now you
have a chance to move further forward
the check comes again and you can block
and this position is resignable for the
player with the black pieces there's
nothing you can do trading rooks doesn't
matter your king is too far away from
the pawn
why is it not an issue with king to g6 i
said king g7 attacking the rook after f4
um good question
so let's go back so king g7
uh okay so you're saying king g6 instead
yeah this shouldn't be a problem for
us either rook f4 should be the same um
i guess you're thinking what if king to
g5 now and the king is a little closer
well
probably here there's a few ways to win
um
but
let me think
i guess the biggest problem here is i
can still just move my king out of the
way
i can play a move like rook to d4 um or
rook a4 or something like this is all
gonna be fine but i can probably i think
the most basic answer is i can still
just move my king out of the way
because you can take my rook but i'm
getting a queen
so
i'm still happy
and if you call checks then these ideas
continue right now i have the bridge i'm
going to step out of the way
again if you take the rook so it gets a
little complicated here probably the
safest move would just be to play
something like rook to d4 um this is
probably going to be the easiest idea is
now the rook is defending the pawn and
once our king steps out of the way
whichever way it steps eventually we can
work our way in front
so yeah i know queen versus work is not
an easy win
but
at a beginner level it shouldn't be too
hard to get your opponent slipping into
some kind of fork
um
okay i don't want to get too caught up
in the weeds just want to give some of
the basic ideas here
but okay so rook f4
and again we looked at kg6 but yeah rook
uh p2 the position is the same the
important idea is we prepare to build
the bridge when we can and there's just
no way to stop promotion
um okay so
somewhat complicated but i think the
basic idea is very instructive
i do want to say there are other ways to
win this position
so
i the reason i'm not going to go into
them is because again my philosophy is
kind of no stress chess what is the
simplest most surefire way to win even
if it's not the most technically
accurate right if you go into a computer
uh or some kind of online board you can
look up the computer or in a position
like this you can go to a table base
table base is just it means there's not
enough pieces on the board to need a
computer the position is just solved
i think every position that has less
than seven or seven or less pieces that
includes the two kings um is solved we
just know the answer um
but
they will sometimes suggest moves
that are
um
a little different than what we're doing
because they're a little faster
so in this case you could play a move
like rook to b2 and you're still going
to be able to win but the reason i would
only recommend this building a bridge
maneuver is because it's the most simple
and the most sound
for instance black can put up a lot of
resistance here
and i'm not going to go into detail
about this line
but just something like rook to c3 again
passing the turn wanting to maintain
defense of all of these squares so the
king can't escape
rook to b7 and white's idea here is
we're going to try and build a bridge
just right here on the seventh rank um
you need the same idea it's just going
to look a little different
the problem is
you know again just passing rook to c7
black and play for some trend rook to a2
into c8 preparing to move out of the way
rook a8 check
let's move stops pawn promotion
into b7
rook to d8 okay white can still win but
now you've let the rook in front of the
pawn um just be there this could be a
little problematic the only move in this
position
for white to win is to play king to c6
if you play into b6 you give black too
much time i don't know why you would
play this move but this gives black too
much time after king to e7 um
black is going to be able to hold a draw
in this position because they can kind
of keep doing all of these checks right
same kind of idea and actually um
if we play it slightly differently
if we play rook 27 here and allow
black's king to step in front then now
we actually need to enter the floater
position and black can hold a draw
because their king is in front of the
pawn
this is maybe not the true filidor but
it's close enough
um okay
white can win here again not trying to
teach why but it gets complicated
um
seven rook a8 rook to b3 this is like
one of the weird tricks of this position
is you have to think very far ahead
so again without asking you to solve
this in this position white can win
really
in only one of two ways one you have to
bring the rook to one of these squares
uh b3 b2 or b1 or you have to play this
kind of really neat move rook to a7
which is pretty neat if you take i take
i get the queen um
here you could win with something like
this
but
the problem is it's funny because if you
play in this position if you don't play
a move like rook to be yeah baby yes
play um rook to b4
then
this is actually not gonna work really
funnily um because the king is just one
square too close so here's an example
rook the a6 um okay we need to keep our
king defending this pawn right if we
move too far away then
this king will just take it
king to b5 tricky move let's go defense
of the pawn axe the rook the rook can
just jump in
and we're not going to be able to sing
um you know something like back we're
just going to take our pawn
doesn't work
if we block with the rook and they just
take and lure us away
that doesn't work
because c5 doesn't work because again we
pawn and we're not making a threat
here's the real cool part of this
position is king to e7 doesn't work
even though we're attacking the rook
um rook to d6 into c8 threatening to
promote um
it looks like
we have a tactic
after rook 67 we have this nice move
check
i think ah we're fine but no king to f5
hacking our rook if we take yours and
they're gonna take ours and this is why
you have to play something like rook to
be three two or one because then the
rook is one space away from this king
you have to see all of that in advance
we're not gonna go too much more into
depth the point isn't to teach you this
kind of crazy line but there are
alternate ways to win this position
um i don't think they're worth
i mean they're worth knowing sometimes
because you can always facilitate this
but it is you know
the very tried and true very simple
method
of simply calling check to force the
king away
say something like kg7 and then
preparing to build the bridge
we are going to bring our king out we
are going to block with the rook and
this should be fairly
simple
um
okay
so
that's the basic idea i want to show
how this occurred in a real game
and this is going to give a few other
kind of basic ideas of the kane rook
endgame and we're not going to get too
much into depth
but i want to show the main ideas and
how you might be able to apply those to
your game so this was a game
or this was a position that took place
in 1941 in a game
in botfunic had the white pieces and
boloslavski had the black pieces and
you'll notice that in this position
everything is equal both sides have two
pawns and a rook the only difference is
i guess white's king is one space
farther away from the center
than blacks and the critical difference
white has a past pawn
so
what does
uh bottom neck do in this game to win
the best move and as suggested by very
aptly named passed upon 99.99
um rook to b1
as i said rooks belong behind the past
pawns
if you play some other moves like if you
just play like h3 will allow
black's work to get behind this past
pawn and you can still defend the pawn
you could play rook to e4 or you could
even play something like rook to e8
check and then move to b4 but as we kind
of saw in the previous example in the
beginning
having our rook in front of the pawn and
even to the side of it is not going to
be as effective as it will be behind
because if the rook is behind the pawn
it controls every space the pawn is
going to go to
if a rook is in front of a pawn and
actually for black sometimes
it's okay to get the rook in front of
the pawn um usually you're still going
to prefer to have it behind but it can
be useful to block the pawn um from
moving forward in some scenarios
but either way upon the rook on the side
this is helpful to a degree but it's
also very hard to maneuver right because
any time we want to move the rook to a
different file we risk losing the pawn
work to be one
in this position the
tried and true method um
someone suggesting rookie 2 here
not sure i follow that india
um let's stick with rook to b1
uh okay so here's what happens in the
game
f7 and perhaps black would have done a
little better to play something like c6
to try and blockade the pawn since
there's no way this rook can get behind
it blockading is still going to be a
nice alternative
but in the game we have king to f7
rookies two got it
okay to f7
um and white plays b5 e6 b6 brook c8
uh preparing to jump in front here on up
eight
and white chooses very critically not to
play b7 here uh just pushing the pawn
aimlessly this is something that i think
a lot of beginner players might fall
into is just i want to get the pawn as
close to promotion as possible this
actually wouldn't be so good um because
now black's king is just too close
and the only way it's going to win this
position is by forcing uh black the
black pieces to essentially pick a side
um they're either going to have to fully
devote themselves to getting rid of this
pawn at the cost of white being able to
pick up these pawns on the king side or
at least some of them
or black is going to have to play more
conservative and try and stop this pawn
while still defending
and
white should be able to hammer one or
both sides effectively because black's
attention is diverted
if you play a move like b7 then this is
going to give black a lot better chance
right rook to b8 i mean something like
it could happen white tries to activate
the king
um kind of a cute little move here rook
to c1
with the idea that you don't want to
take this pawn
um it's playable but it is harder to
activate the king you can play something
like here and then if the king moves
trade and our king is going to be a
little closer it's not good enough to
win but it's you know hard
for the black player
um
here something like king to d6 would
probably be the best
uh preventing the rook from jumping in
to defend on c7 and attack these pawns
for all of these reasons this is not how
white chose to play this game
it's
possibly playable but it's not you know
not worth trying when there's a simpler
solution so here white plays the move h3
preparing to activate
um the king
okay rook to b8 king to h2 into d5
advancing towards the white pawn
white continues to activate
their king with the idea that black can
try and forcibly win this pawn
but after any trade of the rooks
the black king's gonna now is definitely
gonna be too far away that since this
king is more involved it's only gonna
take one or two moves to start messing
up these pawns
so black has to play very carefully
um in this position black plays king to
b7
because as we just said
rook takes king and arcing is going to
be able to
stop black's king from approaching and
it's going to be able to get to these
pawns first this should be a pretty easy
win for white
instead plays into b7 with the idea that
hopefully the king is going to be able
to keep this pawn blockaded and dealt
with and black's rook can now choose to
activate to try and come to the spawn's
defense or maybe even go on the
aggressive so this was voslovsky idea
and white now plays a really nice move
rook to e1
this is important because white is
activating their piece
excuse me
and recognizing that black having cut
off the rook from defense of the pawn
black actually can't take this pawn
because of what we just saw right if the
rook or sorry if the king takes the pawn
then black will very hap or sorry white
will very happily force this exchange
and again white's king is just too close
you're not going to be able to stop the
king from getting in
so this position rook e1
is really nice because black can't
fit spawn and it's also doubling i think
someone in the chat already is ahead of
me twitchwatcher19
with the idea that now that the rooks
doesn't have to keep defending this pawn
it's ready to step in with something
like rook to e7
check trying to win these pawns maybe
rook to e6 to defend from the side but
also put a little more pressure here on
this side of the board
okay so black plays rook to g8
anticipating rook to e7
um
now if rook d7 is played this pawn is
defended and the king will take so rook
to e7 isn't as good anymore which is why
rook to e6 is played instead defending
the pawn from the side
i know we said that defending the pawn
from the back is better which generally
is true
but in this case defending it from the
side is doing its job because white has
kind of switched gears
this is maybe another important lesson
for beginners to learn is it's very easy
to get hyper fixated on an idea and just
want to see it through regardless of
what your opponent is doing in this
position had white gotten so fixated on
trying to promote this pawn
that he let go of everything else then
black can probably hold the draw but
because white is willing to play both
sides of the board and force black to
kind of lose strength in both areas
black's going to be in trouble
so the game continues like this
there are several winning plans
but i'll just show you what actually
happened in the game
so black continues to just kind of
bounce this king back and forth right he
he can't really do anything else the
rook needs to defend these pawns from
any types of check
and the king needs to stay around and
guard the pawn from promotion so here's
what um happens in the game puffinet
continues by dancing
and black is just going to go back and
forth
white advances the pawns
retreats the king to let the pawns move
farther forward and place this really
nice move h6
um something to note is when you're
trying to promote pawn a single pawn um
having a pawn that's not one of these
rook pawns on the very edge is a lot
more successful
a rook pawn is a lot easier to stop
because the king doesn't have to worry
about letting your king be in front
a king just being on the side or sorry
just being in the way is enough to stop
it
but that's not true if the pawn is any
of these center pawns
so
white plays this really nice move h6
um try and force either
uh if this pawn is pushed then now
something like rookie seven
trading off this pawn picking up this
one and preparing to win the game with
the h6 or possibly even g5 pawn this
should be a good enough plan
instead
g takes h6
and white is easily able to pick off
these rook pawns and will eventually use
this one to win
while maintaining defense even still of
the v6 spawn
um black is worked to g7 defending
the king advances king 36
wrote the c6 um hoping now
that
uh the king steps here so in this
position uh rook to e7 was played
but if black kept up with the normal can
he had been doing it bouncing back and
forth this now doesn't work at all
because just very simply you can play
check
the rook is hanging so you have to take
and white's king is well close enough to
just win this game
so uh rook c6 stopping black's plan of
just repeating
the rook to
e7 and rook to c7 now and kind of
forcing this trade we are going to win
this pawn
um
unless you want to trade and we've
already seen that that's not going to
work
group the e5 check we block with the
pawn king takes pawn rook takes pawn
it's still complicated but here's why it
becomes relevant
black now advances the king white slowly
advances the pawn and improves the
position
white keeps the rook uh uses the rook to
keep black's king out of the way
we enter
what should be
this very familiar position
this is the eluxina position just
verbatim this is what happens in the
game
so
how does white win
who in the chat remembers what is the
technique yes few people already saying
it first rookie two we want to force
black's king away
from stopping our king from exiting
right the rook is stopping us from
exiting on this side so we need to stop
the king from exiting or from keeping us
away i work to e2 check
this came to d7
now the excellent move rook to e4 as
suggested by several people in the chat
um with the idea that we built the
bridge right and the way we figure this
out is we see how far away can the king
get from the bottom it can be one space
away which means even one space in front
of that is going to be where we need our
rook so rook to e4 is going to be able
to come here and support our king rook
to h2 is passing the term king to f7
brook to f2 check
and we've seen this before
in this position black resigns there is
nothing left to do
no move can be played with stops
promotion except to take the rook and
that only delays promotion
so in this position uh black resigns
so keep this position in your mind it
happens
at all levels of play um and rook end
games can be especially brutal and
complicated so having this is something
to add into your repertoire if you
weren't familiar before i think is very
useful
obviously these are masters playing at
the highest level
[Music]
is there a term for the technique of
calculating how far movie rook based on
where king is i don't think so
um
i'm not familiar if there's a term i
think building the bridge is just kind
of the term for the whole sequence and
the idea of this luciano position um but
i would just try and keep an eye on you
know
so i believe this is our position i'm
just trying to keep an eye and i i just
think about it where is the king going
to be right because all black is going
to be able to do is called checks so i
think okay i need to defend the pawn and
then i can step one space forward
and if i put my work one space ahead of
that i'll be able to block the check
so this is what i keep in mind
um
okay
so one more thing
we have about 15 minutes left i think we
can start to talk about the filler
position this one is a little more
complicated so we're not going to get
through everything
but the key here and i think again what
i want to emphasize in my philosophy of
no stress chess
is the philidor
is where instead of being able to get
our king in front of the pawn black is
going to be able to get there king in
front of the pawn
so in a position like this where it's
unclear exactly what's going to happen
and i will say the difference here is in
the lucina
because at the beginning we looked
at
like the king in one pawn versus a king
um there is a little bit of a difference
here because in this position um white's
king is in front of the pawn
black's king is not able to stop white
from doing that
in the lucina position it's actually a
little different
well cena the king is literally the only
one in front of the pawn black's king
can not get in front of the pawn
um in the philidor it's the same idea
right black's king is just in front of
the pawn and you cannot
get your king to be in front so
it's more competitive
but in a position like this
it's important to know
that there's a few different ways to
play
white can play by you know trying to
bring their king forward but it can get
you into some trouble if you're not
careful black can play with some tricky
checks and with advancing the king and
trying to get uh their king to set up a
blockade and create a filidor position
which
the pure philidor black can hold a draw
so
very easy way to remember is if you're
in some kind of position this is just a
random example
and you see this as a possibility where
you have one pawn
and you're trying to get your king in
front and stop their king from entering
this philidor blockade
if you have the option to cut off their
king
do so
in this position work to f1
the position
changes dramatically in one move
from a very complicated end game where
you're going to be fighting tooth and
nail
for every bit of advantage and possibly
getting a win possibly not
into just a very simple position where
you've essentially removed one of
black's two only pieces on the board
um so keep this in mind right the
position changes from a complicated
endgame to something that's pretty
trivially easy
just because we're stopping the king
from getting involved
the same can sometimes be true in the
opposite way if you can keep your
opponents king from getting involved in
the defense or
promotion of the pawn you can also gain
some serious advantages there but this
is so so important to remember
an example for how white can very easily
win this game
is let's just say black attacks the pawn
we defend
problem black has
is
we can just continue to make this kind
of little walkway
whenever they check we just leave an
extra space to push the pawn
and without the king able to be involved
you can only ever choose one side to
keep us from
and we can put our rook on the other
side
so this position king g6 was played i'm
sorry
um
but if instead
chooses to stop the camera going this
way then we can bring our rook to e1 and
now there is no way for them to
challenge in this position actually i
think it would work in this position
they would transform right into a lucina
and we would still need to build a
bridge
um
it's a lot easier than the philadelphia
right we've learned how to solve all
this in a position
but if their king is too far away then
we can do the same thing on a different
side
and just bring out the king and promote
keep this in mind right an ounce of
prevention is worth a ton of cure
and if you can avoid getting into a
complicated ending position
definitely recommend it it's going to
save you a lot of stress
now the philidor position
this is the kind of pure kind of
theoretical philidor
and there's a lot of complications here
i don't think i'm going to be able to do
justice to this in the next 10 minutes
so i'm not going to try instead i'm
going to look at a few examples that are
slightly different
the key to remember in the philidor is
it's a lot like the lucina except
black's king is the one in front of the
pawn
sometimes white's king is also going to
be able to be in front they're both
going to be there but black's king being
a blockade is usually enough
um
however i want to show how you can still
win
if black is not playing very well
so this is technically a filing position
black's king is in front of our pawn
um and our king cannot quite get there
so this is a philadelphian the problem
is in this position black can't hold the
draw because their pieces are
very inactive
both pieces are on the back rank and are
just not really involved right this rook
would much rather be somewhere able to
call checks and pastor r king
but because it's not we can actually
find a very nice way to win
so
in this position it is white to move and
play kind of the the really simple
winning idea so i don't have an idea
what you might do here with white to to
win this game even though your
opponent's kind of in this defensive
structure
rookie 7 is suggested in the chat
this is an interesting move
i'm not sure
it's gonna win though
rook a7
uh yes rook a7 does win rookie seven i
think there's a bit of a problem because
after rookie seven
um then black does have i think just
enough time to get their rook and start
calling checks the basic idea of the
philidor is this check thread um
right similar to the lucina except we'll
see that the bridge doesn't quite work
as effectively in the philidor because
the king is in front
not our king so there's even when we can
stop the checks we still can't get their
king out of the way
um a rook to a7 is what wins here uh
yeah no worries about the missed type
happens all the time
um brook to a7 in this position it wins
because black's rook is literally just a
bystander in this position not doing
anything
we're actually making a massive threat
there's no time to position yourself for
these check
this check pattern because we're just
making a main thread
our king and pawns
or sorry pawn work together to
create uh essentially a back rank
checkmate threat
um so the only move to stop it right if
i go here checkmate
any other move checkmate so i have to
play king to e8
but now this is very simple after rook
to a8
and we can just trade the rooks
and you're not close enough to stop
promotion i can just play d7
if you're worried about it you can just
move it in closer either way
um black cannot stop promotion here
similarly
a slightly different example this is
identical except for one complicating
factor in this position um
we're a little closer to the wall with
this pawn
so in this position we can still find a
wind as white but there is one slight
complication
how can we
win here
anyone what's the winning idea for white
yeah rook a7 again but now black has the
trick of instead of having to run this
way they can play rook to b8 because we
don't have any threats of rook to a8
so how do you continue
yes it's c7 the trick here is in this
beautiful position c7 works because
um black only has one move
and after rook to a8 we are picking up
their rook
and we're still promoting so now it's
just even easier you can just make some
kind of ladder mate if you would like to
okay so if blacks king and rook are very
passive you can still get a win if their
king is in front of the pawn
um but here's one position where it
won't work
so the first one we looked at is uh the
pawn is on d6 second one the pawn is on
c6 now the pawn is all the way on b6
this one is close
um
unfortunately we can't quite force the
wind right we would love if we could
swing our rook to the i guess z file
right one behind a
uh off the board over here and threaten
the exact same thing we just did
but because we are limited to the spaces
on the board um this isn't gonna get us
anywhere right rook to a7 there's just
no threats of check there's no threats
of pushing with check
and black is going to be able to hold
but if you try something like rook b7
um
this isn't going to change anything
either because black can just kind of go
back and forth
and you have to be careful in these
types of positions not to get
overzealous
because if you try something like back
here
or let's say we play
in this position b7
threatening to play rook to a8 check and
win the rook and then promote to queen
we have a big issue
the issue
rook to g6 as twitch watchers have said
ouch
not only are we losing the pawn we're
also losing our rook and subsequently
you're losing the game
this is rough so be careful not to get a
little too overzealous
um b7 here doesn't work any better
because now with the pawns out of the
way the rook is activated to start
calling check
um
the king gets far enough away then you
can switch to the bottom row and call
check from behind and this is kind of
the traditional philidor example where
the king is just going to keep it
checked over and over again
okay
five minutes left
i can't explain in detail why this
position is a draw but i can walk you
through the very very basic ideas and um
hopefully in a future video i can
address this further because it is a
very important topic but i want to give
you the real basic rundown so the
important thing about this position
is black's king is blockading our pawn
and they're gonna be able to
uh stop us from ever promoting because
their king and rook are more active
right they're not just sitting on the
back row
the the really tricky simple move in
this position um is rook to h6
we're saying it's black to move here
right work to h6
um
it's a little complicated to explain why
but let me just walk through the basic
line so something like rook to g7 into
e8
brook a7
hoping you know to advance the pawn to
advance our king to threaten some of the
trek mating ideas we were looking at
before
this doesn't work because now rook to g6
it's kind of waiting around black is not
going to let us advance the king
instead we're going to have to choose to
advance the pawn right
there's really nothing else we can do
rook to aa check doesn't actually
accomplish anything
we're just going to go back and forth
you have to advance the pawns to try and
make progress
but now
um that the king can't go hide in front
of it
rook to g1 and these checks again
they start coming and they don't stop
coming
there's just no way to stop
all of these checks the work can always
jump behind e1 it needs to put more
pressure on the pawn
um
and this just gets very complicated
to quickly show
something that's not so good
instead of trying to rook h6 right the
goal here the main goal is to stop the
king from being able to get in front of
the pawn that's what you want to keep in
mind
doing something like rook to
f7 isn't
you know gonna work right this the idea
is maybe we're trying to stop white from
getting any checks
but this it's a hopeless endeavor
because white can just switch to the
other side and threaten checks at any
point they want
and black can still hold the draw here
but you got to be real precise about it
[Music]
something like rook to h1 here
seems to work it's going to give an
active rook and all these checking ideas
but white has a very strong response
after rook to g7
to e8 and king to e6 hoping
black calls check
we can step in front and make some check
mating threats
this gets very scary very quickly for
the black player
so
not the strategy you want want to play
this move rook to h6 um essentially you
want to stop white's king from advancing
so
that's the real basic idea um again we
can get more complicated uh hopefully in
a future video or there's lots of other
great resources on this position both in
books and online um so feel free to
check those out as well
but
this is the basic difference so what we
learned tonight just kind of give the
quick recap
again if you learn nothing else please
remember that your kings belong in front
of pawns the rooks belong behind them
most of the time right a king that is
helped in front of the pawn is going to
either help it promote or stop it from
promoting
and this is true with rooks on or off
the board
and a rook that is behind the pawn is
going to be able to support every square
that it can go to down the board
instead of being either in the way if
it's in front or if it's on the side
it's going to have a harder time letting
the pawn move and stay defended
so rooks behind behind the pawn
the kings belong in front of the pawn
um the lucina position
the very basic idea is once your king is
in front of the pawn what you need to do
is to stop this onslaught of checks by
building a bridge
you force the king
away right not with e7 but with a move
like we're gonna have to
and here
you build the bridge so that when your
king moves forward the rook can jump in
and block a check that is incoming
um
the philidor position
is very similar
uh except black's king is the one who's
in front of the pawn
uh and they're going to with best play
be able to keep your king from from
advancing forwards and eventually when
the time is right when the pawn is
committed to moving forwards swing to
the back row and call checks non-stop
and if you were in a game and you see
this as a possibility
it is always important to remember you
can stop the king from being active and
involved before they ever have a chance
to blockade that's going to really help
out your chess game
so that's all i have for you tonight um
thank you for tuning in everybody
hopefully you learned a little bit about
rook king and pawn end games about these
really famous positions lucina and the
philidor and i hope to see you again
next time take care